chances are whether you love it or hate
it you most certainly have heard of Al
Jazeera and you probably have watched it
but when Saudi Arabia and three Arab
states called for Al Jazeera to shut
down it sparked a wave of global
resistance among the media and human
rights organizations
The Guardian called the attack on al
Jazeera an assault on free speech is the
birth the impact of media in the Arab
world that should be condemned and
resisted and the New York Times
editorial boards that this misguided
attack on al Jazeera was an attempt by
Saudi Arabia and its anticodon coalition
to eliminate a voice that could lead
citizens to question their rulers today
the country is calling for the shutdown
including the United Arab Emirates where
saudi-owned Al Arabiya is base have
passed a law that makes it illegal for
residents to express any support for COD
otherwise they go to jail for up to 15
years or pay a fine of one hundred
thirty six thousand dollars al Jazeera
sees the call for its closure as nothing
short of its siege against the
journalistic profession itself and an
attempt to silence freedom of expression
in the region so I'm here inside the Al
Jazeera English newsroom to talk to some
journalists and find out how do they
really feel about this whole situation
so how does it feel to be covering the
news when you somehow
ardan I think it's more important than
ever that al Jazeera does what it's
always done which is to provide fair and
accurate balanced reporting around the
world I think this is an opportunity to
show that what started many years ago as
a bold experiment and was regarded as a
bold experiment but many parts of the
world has transformed over the years
into a very legitimate news organization
is it distracting in any way shape or
form I think from a work level I have to
be honest nil we concentrate on the
stories that we're doing the stories
that we're trying to tell about the
world to the world on a personal level
of course we know we have families here
with young friends here and we are aware
of the impact
that it's having on the content of the
country yes I was shocked by the news I
think a lot of the world was shocked but
to me you know it's no more shocking
than the war in Syria it's no more
shocking than the government's bombing
civilians it's no more shocking than an
entire southern province of the
Philippines exploding in violence these
are just as shocking if not more
shocking than the Gulf crisis story
everwood's me how did you feel when you
started seeing all the support come in
from human rights organizations from the
media at first I was a bit of the world
was leaving here and then knowing what
might happen and it seemed to support
you know from the Guardians
you know such a team aquas Nation people
from my background Senna garden virus as
well calling me asking me how you feel
and we know that we doing right thank
you you can't just you know ask us to do
things or we're going to go against
freedom of speech so because this is
what this whole thing is about al
Jazeera was established in 1996 it
quickly grew into a multilingual global
media giant building huge audiences in
the Arab world and beyond it broke
censorship norms and reached directly
into the living rooms of tens of
millions of Arab households thirsty for
any alternative to state-run channels
that had been op alized airwaves for
decades the truth is al Jazeera has
stirred public opinion in ways Arab
governments couldn't ignore serving as a
critical source of news as the Arab
uprisings rolled across the region in
2011 but like all media organizations al
Jazeera which arrived to the region long
before the internet has made mistakes
and is accused of not being critical of
God and of following the political
agenda of its host country and its
editorial line still less than 10 years
after its creation al Jazeera was
already ranked the fifth most
influential brand in the world behind
global icons such as Apple Google akia
and Starbucks at a time when Arab states
are increasingly blocking access to news
sites through draconian press laws and
arresting journalists al Jazeera Arabic
remain
among the top viewed news channels in
the region one thing's for sure al
Jazeera has become a news organization
that politicians all around the world
simply can't ignore
[Music]
you